[Music]
my name is Tim Murray and I work on the
Android performance team and we're going
to talk today about improving your
applications performance on Android now
one of the big things that the Android
performance team has done in the past
year was to optimize the performance of
the Google pixel that we looked at
everything on the pixel from application
code all the way down to the kernel
everything in between we tweak things we
experimented with things we replaced
other components entirely what did we
try to do here what did we do to you
know what was our focus for performance
number one we wanted to hit 60 frames
per second all the time this means that
you have to render a frame in 16.7
milliseconds
all the time if you run at 60 frames per
second your app looks fluid your app
looks smooth and responsive if you don't
run at 60 frames per second people
notice the phone doesn't feel fast the
phone feels like it's struggling so that
kind of consistency is paramount you
really want to hit 60 frames per second
all the time the second thing we focused
on was to make applications start
quickly a user will switch between
applications a lot in the course of
normal usage you know if I'm in Gmail
and I click a link that opens in Chrome
I want that to go quickly if I click a
link in you know Chrome that takes me to
Twitter I want that to go quickly to any
time that I'm sitting there waiting for
the system to switch applications feels
like dead time it's time when I remember
that I'm using a computer as opposed to
just interacting with the stuff I want
to get done so reducing the amount of
time you spend switching apps makes the
system feel effortless it's really
important
that's it that's what we focused on
system-wide for pixel we just wanted to
hit those two things consistently if you
do these two things when your device is
you know switching between applications
very quickly and running at 60 frames
per second it'll feel fast but more
importantly if your device runs at 60
frames per second and switches between
apps quickly consistently it does it all
the time the device stops stealing like
anything it stops feeling like a device
instead it feels like you're interacting
directly with the application and that's
magical for a user that's really
important but there's a problem with
this scenario we run apps and apps can
be slow and of course on the system side
of things we're constantly trying to
make it easier to write fast
applications and make it harder to write
slow applications but fundamentally as
an application developer there's always
going to be something you can do to make
the system not run at 60 frames per
second or make your app startup really
slowly the issue is that from the point
of view of the user they don't care that
it's one app that happens to run slowly
one app is that doesn't run at
sixty-fifth or doesn't start up quickly
ruins that whole magical feeling of the
device and it reminds them that they're
not interacting with an app they're
touching their phone and then they want
to throw their phone against the wall so
today we're going to talk about two
tools that we used during pixel really
extensively to analyze performance and
help you as app developers to figure out
what you can do to improve your
applications performance the first tool
we're going to talk about is called GFX
info so GFX info is a shell command that
you can use on the device via dumps this
and all it does is it tell you about the
rendering time for your application so
here we can see that we rendered 223
frames we get the average frame time the
90th 95th and 99th percentile frame time
and then it gives us some idea of why
things were actually slow we use this a
lot internally and we really just look
at average frame time 90th 95th and 99th
percentile frame time and that's it
that's all this tool does it doesn't
tell you why your app ran slow it
doesn't tell you anything that you
should do to fix it so why am i up here
talking about it because you can
automate it if you if you take one thing
away from this talk if you decide to
take a nap for the next half hour
just run GFX info at the very end of
whatever automated test you're running
and congratulations now you have a
performance test now you have a thing
you can run regressions on you can spot
regressions in your application the
first time you have a performance
regression and your application that you
want to track down this will save you so
much time and effort it will pay for
itself instantly this is how most of the
internal Android jank tests work this is
how we track all jank across the system
it's incredibly useful please just do it
you'll save yourself so much time but
okay that's GFX and so that only tells
you where your performances today it
doesn't tell you why your performances
that way or what you should do about it
for that we have to turn to a different
tool my favorite tool really the only
tool I ever use just trades so a lot of
developers have tried to de-stress and
they've told me they have no idea what's
going on when they look at systrace and
that's fair I can stand up here and tell
you that's this trace is easy it's not
really easy
systrace is not a CPU profiler this
trace is instead a system-wide tracing
tool the first thing that means is
systrace doesn't care about your app it
doesn't do anything special to your
application it's not going to go peek at
your applications
pulse tax and say hey you spent a really
long time in this function it doesn't do
that it just tells you when your
application was running and certain
events that occur within your
application it also tells you everything
about the rest of the system it will
tell you things about the kernel it will
tell you things about the graphics
pipeline it'll tell you things about the
framework and activity manager and
things like that really if there's any
information you want about an Android
device we have probably surfaced it via
systrace we use it for everything just
to be just to reinforce how important
this trace is in the past year I've
looked at somewhere over 2000 traces we
use to trace a whole lot now systrace is
not in android studio if you want to get
this trace there are two ways to get it
first of all it's in platform tools in
the Android SDK you can get a version of
this trace from there what I like to do
though is I get this trace from the
repository where it's developed it's
part of a project called catapult which
is on github catapult is owned by
members of the google chrome and Android
teams so upstream catapult is always
improving there are always new features
I usually get papa tree catapult once
you get that you'll have this Python
executable that you can run and you can
get a trace now how does this trace
actually work what does it actually tell
you this trace is three components at
the bottom is this thing called F trace
F trace is a Linux kernel feature that
allows the kernel and user space to
write event information into a central
buffer
what this means basically is that you
can get a journal of any event that
happened on the system so the colonel
will tell us things like hey this
process started running on this CPU or
hey the clocks changed on this CPU
that's great it's really the level but
we can use it the next thing above F
trace is a program called a trace a
trace is an Android program on the
device that is installed automatically
and the Android images on every device
all it really does is it configures F
trace but it also can configures
userspace tracing so a trace will go and
turn on all of these different trace
points inside of the Android user space
so here we can get things like you want
to find out what window manager thought
about your application a trace will turn
that on or activity manager or any other
part of the android framework all of
that is controlled by a trace the
topmost layer is systrace itself this
trace then lives on your host
development machine
and it gets the results from a trace and
it wraps those results in a nice HTML
file you get this giant potentially tens
of Meg's or even hundreds of Meg's HTML
file that contains a trace so all you
have to do to look at the trace is you
open the HTML file it's pretty
convenient and it actually makes sharing
traces incredibly easy now the first
thing you should do when you decide to
start tracing a device is you should
look at the categories available on that
device this trace events are separated
into categories and those categories
will vary from OS versions OS version
and potentially device the device in
general the important stuff will always
be there the core stuff that you want as
an app developer we have tests for that
so they'll be on every device now let's
actually run a trace and see what that
would look like
so this is the command I used for the
trace you'll see for the rest of this
this talk and the way this works is you
provide the list of event tags that you
want in your trace and here we have sket
which is the kernel scheduler we have
freak for CPU frequency information idle
will tell us about C Pete when the CPU
goes idle and W M tell us about the
Android activity manager and window
manager GFX will tell us everything you
ever wanted to know about the Android
graphics pipeline view will tell you
about the view hierarchy inside
applications which can be really useful
dalvik enables the trace point for the
art VM input will tell you when you're
actually touching the screen and binder
driver will tell you exactly when a
process is making an IPC call over
binder to another process the last three
arguments are special dash T just says
we're going to run the trace for five
seconds if you omit the dash T systrace
will just prompt you to press ENTER when
you want to stop tracing - oh just
controls where you write the file so
we're going to write the i/o HTML
instead of trace dot HTML - B is a
little odd so I mentioned F trace and
the F trace buffer the FJ stuffer is a
tick size by default it's I think 1.4
megabytes and what happens if you fill
this buffer if you have too many events
for the buffer is you'll get a trace and
then at the end things will just kind of
stop happening
you think you drank the trace for five
seconds that maybe you only actually
have three and a half seconds worth of
events in there when I take a trace I
always increase the buffer size so here
I've increased it to 16 megabytes and
for this kind of trace we probably don't
have to increase the buffer size but
it's always better to increase the
buffer size and not have to take a trace
a second time then
and be overly conservative with the
buffer sighs all right we run this we
now get a trace what does the trace
actually look like there is a lot going
on in this trace and if you're in the
back I'm sorry it's probably really hard
to see the first thing to know about the
trace is that it is a Timeline view it
moves left to right and you can scroll
it left to right and time moves from
left to right so the left side here is
the beginning of the trace that's 0
seconds when we kicked off the trace and
5 seconds is you know when the trace
ends you can move around the trace you
can move you can pan in time with a and
D keys and you can zoom in and out on
whatever section of the trace you're
looking at with WS so it's just you know
lossky like a first-person shooter the
trace also scrolls up and down so here
you see there are a bunch of rows up
here there's this kernel section and
then a calculator section there are way
more rows and fit on the screen because
there is one row generally for every
thread that is run during the trace so
you may have hundreds or thousands of
rows in your trace the next thing to to
look at when you get start using this
trace is there's this palette of tools
that I have over here in the upper right
hand corner you can click on these tools
you can also access them with numbers
one through four number one is the
pointer that's the main tool we use when
we use this trace that lets us click the
individual events that we see in the
trace and get some information about
them and when you click an event it will
show up in the bottom half of the screen
like that so here we can see calculator
is running we see the process ID we see
the thread ID the priority we can see
when exactly it started in the trace we
see how long and ran for you get a bunch
of useful statistics you can also use
the pointer to select a lot of different
things in the trace which gives you a
aggregate view that looks like that and
so this will basically add up all of the
threads like if I select the region in
the kernel section here this will add up
all of these threads that occurred and
tell us how much time do we spend in
each thread what was the average time
that each thread ran things like that
that's really useful we'll come back to
that later number two and three beyond
the palettes are for panning and zooming
so they're equivalent to WASD you don't
need to use them you can't use them if
you want I generally just use WASD the
fourth tool though it is incredibly
useful it is the highlighter tool so you
could select a region of time in the
trace and that region will have a white
background and everything you haven't
selected will then have a gray
background you can use this to keep
track at the area you care about as you
scroll vertically through a trace so if
you find something in one process and
you think something went wrong here what
else was the system doing you can scroll
up and down the trays and know exactly
what part of the trace you should be
looking at I use a highlighter
constantly if you start using systrace
you probably will as well now let's
scroll down and see what else is in the
trace more stuff so every row in a trace
is either a counter or a thread and down
here at the bottom is a thread these
blocks right here are the core thing
that you will look at in systrace these
are events so every systrace event has a
beginning and an end
this is traits events can then be nested
so this is a stack that grows down you
can see that here a choreographer event
happen
and the eight reversal event was
contained entirely within that event and
more things happened beneath this is
some stuff that's part of a calculator
app startup and you will see a lot of
these as you look through a trace each
event it corresponds to explicit place
in the Android code base that somebody
thought hey maybe if somebody will need
to figure out that this is happening
sometime it's good to pay attention to
dues now let's zoom in on the beginning
of X or at the end of activities start
for calculator so in this trace we
launch the calculator and click a few
buttons here we are at the very end of
activity start and I zoomed in really
closely and it's still probably hard to
see because this trace has a lot of very
small UI elements but there are these
colored bars on top of the UI thread
here these colored bars represent the
state of that thread at any point in
time there are five different states
that a thread can be in now if we click
the green bar above the UI thread in the
middle we see that at this point the
thread was running so at this point the
thread is actually running on a CPU it's
running on CPU 1 and if we were to
scroll back up to the kernel section we
would see it scheduled on CPU 1 this is
how you can know that your application
is actually running at particular times
on the CPU the next state that we care
about is runnable runnable means that
your thread could start running at some
point in time nothing is preventing your
thread from running it's just that the
kernel has not scheduled yet there are
any number of reasons why this could
happen maybe there's more higher
priority work maybe your thread has just
run for a really long time and the
scheduler is trying to be fair and give
other threads an opportunity to run
there are lots of reasons for this if
you if you're seeing a lot of this in
your application it's probably due to
thread priority
the third thing that you can see over on
the right hand side of the tri-series
there's a red bar and the red bar is
uninterruptible sleep which sounds a
little scarier than it is
uninterruptible sleep is your thread is
blocked on some lock inside of the
kernel as an application helper there's
generally not too much you can do with
this
sometimes it's hardware related
sometimes it has to do with memory
usually if if you see a lot of
uninterruptible sleep it's my fault
it's a system problem so what we're
probably aware I'm trying to fix it but
sometimes you can see it's related to
memory you can get some more information
about it the fourth type of state is a
special kind of uninterruptible sleep
that as an application valve you can
actually do something about the orange
state here is your sleeping your thread
is sleeping on block IO this means that
your thread is reading from disk and the
disk hasn't gotten the results back to
your thread so your thread can't make
progress if you see a lot of this in
your trace you're just reading too much
data try not to read so much data the
fifth state the last state is the state
you'll see most often and it's usually
white or gray depending on the
background of the trace it just needs to
thread it sleeping the thread has no
work to do so it is asleep it's not
running the scheduler isn't trying to
run it nothing is working on behalf of
that thread directly in the kernel or
anything like that if you see this a lot
and you think that's weird it's probably
due to some user space lock interaction
because user space locks will show up as
sleeping
the last thing you can do with these
colored bars that are really great is
you can select all of them in a region
that you care about to get aggregate
information so here we can see we spent
so much time sleeping versus runnable
versus running I do this constantly this
gives me a really coarse idea of what
the bottleneck is for a particular piece
of code I can take a trace and see hey
this thread is running it's on the CPU
it should be making progress but it's
just taking too long
what's going on it means that it just
has too much CPU work to do if it's
getting CPU time and not running fast
enough all you can really do is reduce
the amount of CPU work it has to do now
if I take a trace and I see that a
thread is always in block i/o then I
know it's reading too much data from
disk so don't read so much data from
disk if you're sleeping where you don't
expect it probably means that your
application logic is a little weird
somewhere you probably have some weird
priority inversions something or lock
intention that you didn't expect
something like that another useful tool
on a trace is I mentioned the input tag
earlier and up here at the very top
there's this tiny little box for input
response and this shows where I actually
touched the screen in the trace so here
I touched the screen and I guess my
finger was down for 28.8 milliseconds
you can use that in the trace similar to
the highlighter you can use that to
orient yourself in the trace you know
where what's going on if you remember
what you were doing while creating the
trace you can figure out where exactly
you are logically inside that trace but
what if you need more information is not
if you have a lot of information about
what your app is doing logically that
you want to get in a trace good news
that's pretty easy so there is a class
android/ios trace that has two methods
begin section and M section
if you put you can put a string in begin
section and that will just show up as an
event in the trace it shows that the
same as anything else the only special
thing you need to keep in mind here is
you need to call trace the nth section
from the same thread every time you have
a begin section if you don't have a
one-to-one mapping between begin section
and end section your trace will look
weird you will get very weird rendering
in your trace and it's just because you
forgot an end section if you had too
many end sections if we take a trace and
we want to see the app events we have to
do a little bit more than we did
initially first where you can specify
this app's
tag as part of the arguments to the
trace and then we have to pass - a and
the package name that you care about
then you just take a normal trace like
that and you open it up and you see this
trace event which is just whatever you
put in your string if you have logical
groupings of work or a logical task that
the user is doing adding a trace event
for that is really useful when I look at
large complex application within Google
I find that the applications I can debug
easily and understand the performance of
easily are the ones that implement their
own application trace events I
definitely recommend doing it it's not
that difficult and it will be worth it
as you start looking at sisterand it
will make systrace a lot more
comprehensible and for reading a trace
that's about it
there's not really that much going on in
a trait it's just sort of what the
system is doing at any point in time and
everything that the system is doing at
any point in time ends up looking like
this so now what
I don't think most of you probably feel
that comfortable using systrace yet so
why would we want to use systrace what
is what is systrace going to tell us
that makes it so useful let's go back to
the two goals that we had for pixel
number one 60 frames per second number 2
makes apps start quickly ok yes this
trace can tell us some things about this
directly but there's an underlying
principle here that we should call out
don't look slow that's it that's that's
really the only performance rule there
is the reason why we use systrace is it
can tell us where we look slow and note
that I said don't look slow I didn't say
don't be slow this may sound weird
coming from a person who works on
performance but for any moderately
complex application at some point in
time you're going to have to do
something that is slow maybe you're
going to do some giant matrix multiply
for some reason maybe you're going to
read from disk you have to read a large
image maybe you have to talk to the
network which could take who knows how
long at that point you want to
understand why did the system end up
looking slow when I was doing this and
then what can I do to work around it
you know you have to be this slow thing
what can you do in your application to
identify where exactly that slow point
happened and then work around it to make
the system still look fast because
that's all the user care about they
don't care if the system is flow or is
fast they just want the system to feel
fast if you do that it'll be great now
let's apply that to the two goals that
we had app startup
the basic thing with systrace an app
startup is you can use this trace to
figure out exactly where your time is
going during app startup then you can
decide what to do about it
and there's no one-size-fits-all advice
here really you have to understand what
your particular application is doing
what the needs of your application are
and then you can come up with a solution
the first thing that we use systrace for
to analyze app startup is view inflation
here we have this inflate section in a
trace this is from the very beginning of
calculator from activity start and
calculator and we have this really long
inflate section but more importantly we
can see the exact cost of inflating
every view for calculator this is really
useful to help you figure out the cost
of a view hierarchy or changing your
view hierarchy you can say is it
actually worth you know 50 milliseconds
to inflate all these views right now
could I do this later could I do
something else instead you have to come
up with whatever solution is right for
your application
but systrace can help you figure out
what is actually happening today in your
application so you can come up with
those improvements and those ideas put
future changes to your app another thing
that fistrick tells you is you can tell
exactly when application startup ended
from the users point of view there's
more than just bind application and
activity start and application start up
here you can actually see the UI thread
and render thread of your application
which are the two most important threads
in making your application run at 60
frames per second and we know that once
those app once those threads have
finished for the first time here you see
the UI thread running and finishing this
choreographer do frame along with the
render thread running at the same time
once that's done the app is actually
loaded and ready for user input at that
point from the users point of view app
startup is done
another useful thing and systrace is the
resource tag read so you can look at
exactly what resources you're loading in
your application at any point in time
usually loading resources is not a huge
deal
occasionally we've seen areas where
resource loading can be expensive it's
worth checking in your application it
will tell you just as the name of an
event exactly what resource you're
loading and how long it takes and again
you can figure out is it worth letting
this resource right now all right let's
move to jank because that's the that's
the more fun one
fixing jank with systrace is a two-step
process number one you need to figure
out where the jank actually happens
because maybe you can spot every time
the system doesn't run at 60 frames per
second but I've been doing this
full-time for a while now I can't even
do that so sister eyes can help it help
make it really obvious where exactly you
drop the frame the second step that use
systrace for is working your way
backwards from the dropped frame to what
actually went wrong and then you can
figure out what to do about it so here
we have a UI thread and render thread
again in an application and we're
running the thread or the application
normally it's not a janky frame it's
just normal 60 frames per second we're
rendering the UI thread is the main
application thread that's what actually
gets you know input events from system
server render thread actually gets
information from the UI thread and send
that to the GPU this means that in order
to display a frame on time the UI thread
in the render thread has to complete
within sixteen point seven milliseconds
every time this gives this trace is a
nice kind of rhythm you can get used to
this rhythm when you open a systrace and
say oh yeah dropped a friend there
because you can tell it it didn't quite
line up it makes it easy to spot where
the UI pipeline didn't run at a full 60
frames per second once you get used to
this now if that's not enough you can
look at surface planar so we're not
going to be on time to go through the
full Android UI pipeline but the
high-level overview is your app will
render a frame and it will send that
frame over to surface flinger surface
flinger is a system service that will
take whatever app is rendering on the
screen and it will combine that with the
navigation bar and the status bar and
actually send the resulting full
completed composited frame to the
display to show up on the screen what
this means is that surface flinger is
the central source of truth if service
pointer thinks you hit your frame
deadline you're running at 60 frames per
second if surface flinger says you
didn't deliver a frame
you know you didn't actually hit 60
frames per second and here the way we
can do that is we have a counter here
there is one counter per application in
a trace this counter here is alternating
between zero and one for how many frames
the surface flinger have from this
application that are ready to be
displayed so you know that if the
counter goes to zero for more than 16
milliseconds you have definitely missed
the frame this is the ultimate way to
know whether you had janked in your
application or not this gets us this
helps us spot where the problem is it
helps us know where you actually drop
the frame so what do you do when you
know where the problem is you can work
your way backwards so we're going to
look at the surface flinger to work our
way backwards we're looking at surface
flinger just as an example of a
relatively simple chain here because
application chains can't be more
we don't quite have time but usually you
want to know why something woke up so we
have a running state in the application
and we want to know what made it
runnable because that will tell us why
the thread woke up in the first place
so here I click the running State on top
of surface flinger and I can hit the
left arrow and I can see the runnable
state now I have the runnable state
selected and I want to go ahead and
highlight that you can highlight
anything you currently have selected
with the M key now we have a nice little
bar showing what we're looking at in the
trace in this runnable section we have
an additional argument at the bottom
here it says wake up from that tid 529
this means that the surface singer
thread was triggered by Fred 529 now I
don't know what thread 529 is but I do
know that thread 529 must be running at
this point because if thread 529 wasn't
running it couldn't have woken up
service winner so I can scroll back up
to the top of the trace to see what is
actually running on the CPU and I see
this thing event Fred so I'll click
event thread and event thread is part of
source layer
it's another thread inside of the
surface flinger process and now I want
to know what welcomed that event thread
because I'm working my way backwards
from to figure out why surface ling'er
woke up at all here so I'll scroll back
down and find event thread inside of
surface flinger and there's the actual
thread state for the event thread we
just have that little colored bar to
show that it's running because it
doesn't have any event during that time
we can click the runnable section of the
event thread and see that it woke up
from thread 4568 now I cheated I know
what thread 4568 is it is the display
think Fred that is also one surface
layer so let's go to that one and see
what woke up the display syncs for it
that's right down there we click it we
see wake up from PID 0 PA d 0 is a
special thing in a trace and it all it
means is that whatever thread you're
looking at was woken up by an interrupt
of some sort is woken up by an interrupt
handler usually this means a timer
expired
this makes sense for surface flinger
servers flinger will run every 16
milliseconds so a timer expired look at
this display synchronization thread
which in turn look at the event thread
which then welcome surface flinger if
you see this in your trace it usually
means that some timer expired and woke
up your thread and that's why you're
running and that's it that's the basics
of what you need to know to actually get
somewhere with this trace take some
traces of your application and just try
to see what's going on look at the
system look at how frames are being
drawn and sent to the display and how
you're getting touch input from the
server this kind of tracing backwards
via the runnable state is most of what
we do to understand how the system fits
together and you can use it to improve
your applications as well now if you
want a lot more advice on what you
should do as opposed to how to
understand what's going on today I
recommend you go to the there's an
additional Android performance talk
specifically on the UI pipeline that
chet haase and Chris Craig are giving
it's at Friday at 1:30 p.m. so
definitely go to that I know they're
going to talk a bunch about recyclerview
and optimizations there which is always
a popular topic so that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]